hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my video for the ending of x-men Dark
Phoenix as well as a little end tag
scene that they have at the end if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're doing that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave an x-men
comment or a Dark Phoenix comment on the
video obviously spoiler warning for the
ending of Dark Phoenix if you haven't
seen it yet because I'll be literally
talking about everything that happens at
the end of the movie but really quick
Jessica Chastain's character comes to
Planet Earth seeking the Phoenix force
she's the leader of an alien
shape-shifting group called the d'bari
her real name is luck if that sounds
confusing why would they go with that
instead of doing something like the
scrolls I actually do think in the
original version of this movie they were
meant to be the scrolls but then when
they found out that the Captain Marvel
movie was using the scrolls in a big
twist in the movie started to be too
similar to the Captain Marvel movie they
probably had to find something to change
it to it's still a comic book Easter Egg
the d'bari are a race of aliens in the
solar system where the Phoenix force
drained the energy out of a star
destroying the entire system I think it
was something like a half a million
people the Jean Grey as the Phoenix
winds up killing so becomes this big WTF
moment in the comics so the way they
explain them in the movie is that a
small group of them escaped including
Jessica Chastain's character they're
following the Phoenix force across the
universe and it just happened to come to
Planet Earth and enter Jean Grey so
they're trying to take the Phoenix force
out of Jean Grey or control her so that
they can use that power to make their
race great again make the d'bari great
again make all the jokes you want about
that like I said a hundred percent I
think that they were supposed to be the
scrolls in the original version of the
movie and she would have been the scroll
Empress it would have been a much bigger
WTF it would have been a much bigger
payoff for the fans that is not the
first thing that they had to change
about the end of the movie like they
said a couple weeks ago they completely
reshot the third act of the film because
it was supposed to end in outer space
whereas it ended up ending on planet
earth so to speak there is some space
stuff that goes on that I'll get to in a
second but basically the end of the
movie starts during that big train fight
where you have the Brotherhood of
mutants with Magneto and Professor X
with his x-men all locked up then booked
and heard debarry
alien soldiers come for them up to that
point in the movie the Brotherhood of
mutants has been fighting Professor X
couple of our core characters have
switch sides like bees twos now going
against professor X because of the death
of mystique while this little Civil War
is going they get locked up and they're
taken on this train but when Jessica
Chastain's buck character and her other
alien brethren come to take the Phoenix
force and kill them off they have to ban
together Magneto's team and Professor
X's x-men band together they all come
together to try and save Jean Grey and
by this point in the movie the cosmic
Phoenix force has started to take over
her personality more and more she
exhibits more and more powerful acts as
the film goes on so by the end of this
movie she's full-on disintegrating
people Thanos snap style Jean Grey is
floating in the air you've seen it all
in the trailers where she starts to pick
the train up and spin it around so
you've all the x-men all the Brotherhood
fighting the normal aliens while Jean
Grey is picking the train up off the
tracks spinning it around blowing up
bits of it as they go buck gets close to
Jean Grey and tries to siphon the force
out of her again she's trying to do it a
couple times in the movie forcibly take
the Phoenix force out of her body but
Jean Grey fully interfaces with the
Phoenix and unlocks her full potential
going full cosmic force and just
incinerates Jessica Chastain's buck
character but seemingly they think the
Jean Grey is dead when really she's just
evolved into the full cosmic Phoenix
force so technically she's not dead but
she flies off into outer space but they
only see the Phoenix force flying off
into outer space they don't see jeans
body or anything like that and they try
to do an homage to 2001 Space Odyssey
with a sequence of her becoming full
cosmic Phoenix force where you're sort
of passing through the wormhole evolving
as a human
so it's Jean Grey evolving to final boss
form Phoenix obviously they're not gonna
be any more x-men movies within this
universe so you're just left to wonder
what the Phoenix force is going to be
doing in the universe now Professor X
and Magneto pick up the pieces they go
back home there's a little bit of a time
jump Professor X renamed the school to
the Jean Grey school for gifted
youngsters as a way to honor her memory
because they still think that she's dead
it ever since the beginning of the movie
Professor X has not been able to read
Jean Grey's mind because she's become so
powerful so he can't read her cosmic
force mind to know that she's still
alive
so there
trying to memorialize her but what
happens is his professor Eck's basically
owns up to all the Misty's that he had
during the film there was this running
plotline with him being really selfish
being vain liking all the attention that
he was getting from the president the
United States being on the covers of all
these magazines you put us in danger
Charles you put those kids in danger
what kids anymore Raven don't care about
their safety just as much as you do are
you sure about that cuz we're taking
bigger and bigger risks and for what
please tell me it's not your ego being
on the cover of magazines getting a
medal from the president you like it
don't you as opposed to being hunted and
despised well you know actually I do
it's all just a means to an end Raven
what end is that keeping us safe you
should understand better than anyone
that we're only ever one bad day away
from them starting to see us as the
enemy again so what we wear matching
costumes and smile and pictures pay for
keeping the peace by risking our people
to save their yes yes so he owns up to
putting the x-men in too much danger in
the name of all this fame that they were
achieving so as penance he hands over
leadership of the school to the
surviving x-men and they just continue
running it like the normal x-men school
in the comics but Professor X leaves
with magneto to go travel the world so
the weird thing about this is that
they're still pretty young but if you
actually count when magneto was born
remember he was in Auschwitz he's over
60 years old so Michael Fassbender is
over 60 years old during this movie it's
almost exactly like the ending of The
Dark Knight Returns remember the Dark
Knight trilogy at the end of that
Christian Bale's Batman supposedly just
makes it seem like he's dead and then
leaves to go travel the world with
Catwoman and just go on a permanent
vacation he's already given and
sacrificed so much it's time for him to
enjoy himself a little bit I would look
across the tables and I'll see you there
we don't wife might be yeah a couple of
kids
you wouldn't say anything to me no me to
you but we both doubt you'd paid it that
you were happy but I don't exactly think
that's what's going on with Professor X
and Magneto
but they sit down at a cafe to play some
chess so professor X is waiting magneto
walks up and sits down and they start
playing magneto makes the first chess
move and it's meant to be a big Easter
egg reference to the scene of Professor
X Patrick Stewart's Professor X playing
chess with Ian McKellen's magneto at the
end of the first x-men movie in that
plastic cell and then magneto during
that scene says I made the first move
so magneto making the first move during
the end of Dark Phoenix is just a
reference to that the war is still
coming Charles and I intend to fight it
by any means necessary
and I will always be old friend
but also while that's happening the
camera sort of pans out and you see the
sky you see this giant Phoenix shape
forming in orbit so it's just a way to
reference that the Phoenix force is
still out there Jean Grey is still alive
in cosmic form albeit so who knows you
could write as much fanfiction as you
want about what happens after this
within Jean Grey has been extinguished I
creation but then just like Avengers
endgame they do the same sort of
post-credit scene type of thing where at
the very end they play a music cue that
sounds exactly like the x-men the
animated series theme if you don't
remember that I played an orchestral
version of it at the beginning of this
video and I played at the end of a lot
of my other Marvel videos too
an interesting call back to that
animated series I still think that the
animated version of the x-men Dark
Phoenix saga is still the best one but
for those of you asking what's gonna
happen with the x-men next Kevin Feige
did say that there would be a bit of a
cooling-off period even though he can
use them as soon as he wants they just
released this movie I think it's gonna
be a couple years before we see him
actually use any of the really big
mainstream x-men characters it's more
likely that the Fantastic Four would get
rebooted first because it's been even
longer since we've seen that last movie
there have been a lot of rumors about a
possible Marvel phase for Fantastic Four
movie I will do a video about that
sometime later this weekend or next week
once you have a chance to see the movie
just let me know in the comments what
you think of it and what you want Marvel
and Kevin Feige to do with the x-men
characters once he does start putting
them back in the MCU while you wait for
everything click here for that brand new
spider-man far from home trailer and to
listen to Tom Holland to talk about a
bunch of Avengers and game deleted
scenes and click here for that brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight